hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 101 of game
programming freakin Happy New Year guys
it's the second of January right now I
was actually gonna make a make a video
last year or 31st of from very last day
of last year but unfortunately however
it didn't freakin record so that's
annoying but anyway we're gonna hop into
this this year's gonna be freakin
awesome I promise you guys and today
we're gonna be I guess
continuing our kind of a sausage I've
heard that if I open that real quick you
guys will be able to see that we did in
fact finish it here it is this fine path
method in the level class right what
this does of course I'll quickly go
through this in case you guys have
forgotten or something essentially we uh
I guess we enter a star coordinate
another coordinate which is where we
want to go and then what this what this
method does is it calculates a path to
that from the star to the goal right and
what it returns here is a list of nodes
so what it means is it actually traces
the path once it figures it out and
returns it as an ArrayList of nodes now
nodes of the betterment vectors because
nodes also contain the parents and other
information but they're but the main
thing that we're gonna use from now of
course is this this style vector to I
okay because that's essentially the next
step of where we want to go right now if
they're if no path and then obviously
returns the path if no path is found it
returns null okay so what we will do to
test this out because if we run this
right now what we're gonna go going on
is this guy he moves we've got different
kind of they're different kinds of mobs
we've got this guy these mobs who just
move around randomly we've got we've got
this king card world this red guy who
kind of just follows us for a bit but
then stops and obviously he can't go
through walls or anything so if we were
to trick him like that he's not gonna be
able to as you can see he's not gonna be
able to pass that wall and get to us
because he's stupid
now let's I guess to demonstrate this
I'm just gonna make a new mob right so
right-click new class quartz star cuz
the a star search logarithm hilarious
hit finish and this mob is gonna
basically be the same as our chaser
right in fact I'm just gonna pretty much
go ctrl I am just gonna grab all this
copy it and and paste it into Stark and
make sure we of course it's
and mold alright and of course I'm gonna
have to change a few things like this
this constructor here the sprites gonna
be the same sorry not mobster the
sprites gonna the sprites are gonna be
the same the move method and the update
are largely going to be the same in the
render of court is going to be the same
one thing I do want to do there just to
kind of randomize I guess what it looks
like is if we ctrl click on render mode
to go to render mob I'm just gonna pick
out a nice color like a nice kind of
yellow color probably this color right
here so okay so what we're gonna do is
want to say if mob is an instance of
star right and the color is that little
purple default color let's import our by
the way we'll change it to to this color
right here alright and that color case
you guys were wondering that color is
this one right here okay color pick it
up comm paste that in it's kind of like
a yellow gold kind of the saturated kind
of darkest yellow color okay so what's
that what that's gonna do is it largely
just allow us to tell the difference
between all the other different mobs
that we've made so we go into our level
sorry spawn level glass because that's
the class that actually spawns these
things let's go ahead and add a new will
add a new start at level and we'll put
it at coordinates 1735 so probably just
a bit higher up then that one because I
remember that one's like a middle and I
move it a bit to the left so that it's
it's kind of not because that because
there's there's that kind of like pillar
thing in the way we don't want that to
be the way I don't know his corner smart
might end us up inside a wall but we'll
see um all right great so the other
thing we want to do is well sit as close
a few these things so we don't need to
know do we need chaser or screen
Osbourne level anymore right okay so
first of all let's get rid of so the I
guess the AI cuz we just we just copied
and pasted this from from chaser didn't
we the difference I guess or the AI of
that chaser was essentially just this
right just this so if we delete that I'm
I'm
I move right so let's just run the game
to see if we get that star and there is
that's actually perfect look at right in
the middle brilliant so that this is
this is the mob right that where can I
actually make I guess the I start work
on okay so this star mob that's actually
very fitting there's that he's all
yellow and stuff but um this star mob
right we're actually going to give him
the a star search algorithm so that he
can find and follow the player so what
should happen right once we complete
this is if we if we get our player all
the way over here he should be able to
find a way around this wall and
essentially just I guess moved to our
position okay so that's the goal for
this episode and we're gonna we're gonna
start doing that right now
okay so first thing we need to do is
actually I guess call this this method
right we've got this fine path method
which is what's gonna actually find a
path using the a-star search algorithm
here we of course have access to the
level class because every single entity
needs to be initialized when it gets add
and this init method here sets the level
to the current level okay so it's pretty
simple and very common frameworks on
other words if you want an SE to be
inside a level you have to that the
level actually adds that entity and then
references this as the level that it's
contained within so in other words an
entity can't just exist it has to be
contained inside a level and that level
has to spawn it which makes sense when
you think about right very very very
very very very very very simple all
right a lot of varies right there
because I'm freaking excited
okay so first video the years do this so
I'm gonna try and do this without any
errors so px that's gonna be our players
location so the way we can get that a
level dog get player at index 0 I get X
all right so those gonna do is get the
x-coordinate of the player now very very
important you guys realize this this is
going to be in pixel precision that's a
huge difference right there's tile
precision and then there's pixel
precision table precision is the actual
I guess
well tile precision is the easy one
right that's just that that's just the
coordinate of a particular tile on a map
so like 17 comma 31
which is exactly what we did to our um
star here we added them a 17 by 35 pixel
precision is also very important because
precision is like the absolute pixel
kind of location of where he is in the
level right because our entities can't
just move from tile to tile that would
be boring that would be kind of like a
yeah if we could just move like we can't
move in between tiles so he just hop
over to the next tile then to the next
tile that kind of stuff that's very
different we don't do that right we get
to move smoothly in between tiles right
we don't just hop to the next tile so
because of that we have pixel precision
now this of course the get X of course
of the location of the players since we
can move in between tiles it's going to
be in pixel precision right so in other
words it's gonna be something like 260
rather than something like you know 17
all right it's gonna be like something
like 260 instead of 17 okay and that
that that can be an issue okay because
obviously you might you might have
noticed that when we run this find path
algorithm what happens here is we assume
you can see that we get a tile that we
get tile we just get X plus X I so in
other words these two vectors have to be
in tile precision not in pixel precision
because we're finding the path between
one tile and another tile okay so that's
something that's really important okay
because I imagine a lot of bugs would
come there and I have that I have
actually made that mistake before so
let's also get the the y coordinate here
all right so I've let's make it vector
out of Isabel since when you have fade
in vectors into our parameters here the
other thing that's really important is
that well let's actually okay so let's
um in other words what I've just
mentioned right I've talked about top
precision and pixel precision the reason
I've talked about that stuff is because
now that we have px and pixel precision
to convert it back into tile precision
right we simply need to we simply need
to kind of well divide it by 16 right
because the tile is 16 by 16 pixels 16
pixels wide and 16 pixels high and
because the tile is that
we know that if we want to convert from
pixel guitar precision we divide it by
16 if we want to convert from tile to
pixel precision we multiply it by 16
okay very simple stuff so now we've done
that I've gone over that the start is
not gonna be the players position that's
gonna be the goal right the starts gonna
be our current location well I guess the
location of this current star we can use
the gap get X and get Y methods to get
that location so we'll go get X yeah Y
but wait let's import that but wait okay
that remember is in pixel precision as
well but the vector that we make needs
to be int our precision so to do that
we're going to pretty much divided by
six standing so then look on a writer
like that I'm actually going to write it
like this okay
divided by 16 okay and of course this
sorry big mistake there so [ __ ] instead
of divided by 16 I'm gonna go shift
right by 4 and that's the same right
because 2 to the power of 4 is 16 and a
shift right in the case of division
essentially we'll do the same thing with
this okay it's just gonna be a bit
faster since we'll be running this very
often now the other thing is the
destination and the destination is going
to be the PX that we just made again
shifted right 4 and the py shifted right
4 ok so this is going to divide them
both by 16 pretty simple stuff a lot of
people say why don't you just write
divided by 16 4 for readability honestly
this is as readable to me if not if you
guys don't know you pals or to like the
back of your hand and well you should
get on that now this is where it's gonna
this squad is kind of gonna get awesome
we want to we want to now I guess keep a
list of those nodes right because level
returns this fine path method returns a
list of nodes and we want to be able to
access those nodes so we want to make an
array list of nodes here instead of
equal to that fine path method now we
don't want to do that every single frame
okay we could but what happens is if we
start doing that kind of thing every
single update because this is the move
method is of course in update and if we
call it every single update it's just
gonna be a bits gonna get a bit slower
okay this a star search algorithm is
really efficient
but it is still as you can see quite a
lot for your processor to process right
and it's alright if we've got one entity
but we've got one kind of star object
what if we've got like this star entity
what if we've got like a thousand of
them in a level and they're all
accessing the the a style set I'll go to
them 60 times per second you know that
means right that's 60,000 a star search
algorithm processes in one second that's
a lot okay we don't want to do that
that's just gonna slow down especially
on slower computers so what we want to
do is create a global variable here not
only a global variable it's called a
field actually I want to create a field
here which is gonna be an ArrayList of
nodes and I'm gonna set this equal to
path alright and what we're gonna do
right by default and let's just import
our node here we'll set it equal to null
by default okay
and what we'll do is for now right we
just want to go ahead and say path
equals level dot find path and then the
start and goal okay and the goal of the
destination all right now I'm just for
now I'm not gonna I'm not gonna make it
not run every single update just so I
can demonstrate it but we'll fix that in
a minute
okay so we've just admitted here the
path can sometimes be null and
especially it will be null sometimes
because occasionally you might close a
door behind yourself in this game and
there might not be a way anymore for an
entity to get to you or for anyone just
might not be a part of between two
locations in the map right because of
whatever circumstance so occasionally
puff is not so what we want to do is we
want to first of all check if Arthur's
null because if path is null we can't
use it
so if path does not equal null we're
gonna do whatever's here otherwise we'll
just not move at all because X a and Y
as you can see will be 0 so we're not
gonna move anywhere ok you could also do
your else here and then be like alright
well if there is no path to the player
let's just move randomly or whatever
other AI you kind of want to script in
here but for now we're just gonna leave
it at that
so in other words if there is no path
Aaron she's not going to move there at
the moment there should always be a path
so that's all right so if path oops
if path dot size is greater than 0 okay
and this one's gonna get interesting
we're gonna actually create a vector
here
cool dogs call it vac equals path dot
get paths dot size minus 1 dot tile
because tile is the vector from that
oops
file contacted a alright you guys might
be all confused what's going on here
so let's open paint.net and get down to
this explanation stuff right so what
we've got going on right now is let's
grab a nice little orange color this is
the this is the star entity this is the
player up here and we want to get to the
player ok so what happens is we run the
ACE also algorithm it gives us a bunch
of nodes of how to get to the player
right and then what we have to do is
kind of follow those nodes now it's very
important if you go back to level you'll
actually be able to see that in in other
words if we do find that and if we do
find our goal right in other words if
the SRO them actually finds the goal
which it will want sure anyway in this
current map if it does find the goal
what is gonna do is gonna go through
every single node here that it used to
get there right it's gonna make a new
ArrayList here and it's just gonna trace
back the parent okay so in other words
while current or parent equals null
because doesn't equal null because if
current parent is no it means it's the
very first node right because you can
see the first node we create here has a
parent of null if if in other words if
the current node is not the first node
then keep tracing back our steps let's
add the current one and set current
equal to current our parents so what it
does is the a-star search algorithm you
know this is it it finds the path to the
end and when it does it's gonna start
adding number one number two number
three number four number five Number six
number seven whatever okay it's gonna
add those in this order to dr2 the
ArrayList here okay and then return it
now that's important because it doesn't
do it in the other order so that means
that the first the first node in there
is the one closest to the destination
not closest to the the origin the start
okay we have to account for that so
instead of having to go this way we
actually have to go
okay move to know the 7 first then 6 and
5 and 4 then 3 then 2 then 1 then there
ok like that not the other way around
and because of that we can't simply go
path or get 0 because that would be the
one closest to the destination we go the
opposite pretty much path top size - one
part size is of course the amount of
nodes in this path ArrayList and we use
minus 1 here because of course it starts
at 0 not 1 so if we if we if we call
this it's just gonna crash with a list
index out of bounds kind of thing
all right great so let's um let's kind
of do a I here very very simple stuff if
X being our current X is less than
vector don't get X and we want to all
make sure that you actually multiply
this now by 16 right do that because
because this vector is going to be in
tile precision but our x-coordinate of
course is in pixel precision so if that
is the case then let's move it by well
it's just plus plus okay X I plus plus
so in other words if we are if if our
current location is too small as far as
the X goes in other words if the X that
we're supposed to move to is to the
right of our current X then increase XA
in order to move to the right okay
simple stuff we actually covered this
for um for our chaser alright we had
this system here we're gonna do the same
thing here except instead of going to
the player now it's gonna go to that
vector coordinate this is very simple
code that will just allow you to whoops
that will just allow you to UM to move
from one location of the map to the
other okay from one point to another
changes to why a of course and why y
greater than greater than Y Y all right
that's what this is gonna do is of
course just simply move our current star
towards this vector here okay simple
stuff and that's it I can't have to
actually it that's gonna work now I
talked about efficiency let's talk about
that now let's make a let's make an
integer called time set it equal to zero
every update will increment
and what we'll say is we'll only update
the path if if time is less you say once
per second right so if time mod 60
equals zero so once per second
we'll update this now that's good that's
gonna be a bit too slow you'll find
because it doesn't take us a second to
move to the next node but that's just
gonna be a good kind of for a
presentation of what's going on okay so
you guys might be like all right well if
you always get passed out size minus one
if you always get this how is it gonna
go past the last node well the thing is
since we recalculate a path which is
important and inevitable by the way we
could have easily just just gone ahead
and say you know want calculate the path
once and then just go for go first to
this one then this one then this one
then this one then this one then this
one then this one okay we didn't have to
recalculate the path but if we do that
the player obviously has the capability
to move so the player might have moved
over here by now but you know this guy
is just getting here now okay so our um
our orange kind of blob is just getting
here but the players already moved so
there's no point okay unless you want
the mob to behave that way and we might
cover that in the future if it's
requested or if I think that it will fit
into began nicely as a as an enemy type
or something that it always just I guess
goes to your last location first and
then follows your steps but in this case
we kind of want the the I guess the mob
to move to the players current location
so with the play moved if the player
moves this way our mob is no longer
going this way it's actually going this
way now okay that's what we're gonna do
at least for now so in order to do that
what how this works is because it's
recalculating the path it knows that it
it takes in the current location of this
guy again so if we moved up to node six
right we're already here right and then
it recalculate recalculates the path
here and then it gets the closest one
the closest node to us which is now this
node okay because we were already here
we're not here anymore
we're here okay and it moves over to
this node and then it keeps going until
it reaches the destination so in other
words it's always getting the closest
node to itself so let's run this and see
what happens all right so you can see
the slow thing right this
moving once per second pretty much but
you can see he's coming to us alright so
it's working in a way yeah he's coming
to us now let's see if we can get around
walls right let's kind of move up here
and I don't think the mob collision is
perfect either so so just just beware if
you can't if you can't go across walls
or something that that's my bad
let's making okay so let's go over here
let's see if we can make it across this
corner okay sway try that out so you can
see he's actually walking across this
and he gets stuck here and that's just
because of my collision occurred because
we changed around a lot of the collision
and we didn't update it from mobs yet so
that's the reason for that but um
because he's coming at us let's go
across the wall here and you can see he
actually moves up that he's moving up
areas he's coming towards us and
troubling we're stuck here yep what's
making go this way there is see so
that's awesome right he has the
capability here to move across walls
let's go over here see if he comes to us
no let's just stop this this crap let's
make this mod like three so twenty times
a second that should make him move as
you can see a lot faster here and let's
just he's gonna get stuck unfortunately
I'm gonna probably fix collisions for
next episode or something but let's see
if we can find us he is programming yet
stuck somewhere no there is see try that
out and he found us so now I can walk
through walls now there are a few quirks
apart from the collision which is
horrible probably should fix collision
first but there are a few quirks and
that is he sometimes changes directions
randomly that's alright that's probably
just we can iron out those aesthetical
features a bit later but the main thing
is that the algorithm is working
properly and you can see it is alright
so that's awesome
anyway that's probably gonna close off
this episode hope you guys enjoyed it
thanks for watching and next time we're
probably gonna fix this collision stuff
because it's bugging me it's not really
working properly at all as you can see
and it's getting annoying anyway that is
the a-star search algorithm working now
hope you guys enjoyed if you did please
hit the like button I appreciate that
and I'll see you guys in the next
episode goodbye
you